THANKS, HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND
>> Bret: THANK YOU
♪♪
.
>> Jesse: HAVE YOU EVER DEALT
WITH A SALESMAN THAT WASN'T
REALLY CUT OUT FOR THE JOB,
MAYBE COULDN'T MASTER THE SALES
PITCH?
>> OUR NEW BREAK PADS ARE REALLY
COOL.
YOU'RE NOT EVEN GOING TO BELIEVE
IT.
LET'S SAY YOU'RE DRIVING AGO
ALONG THE ROAD WITH YOUR FAMILY
AND YOU'RE DRIVING ALONG, LA LA,
AND THERE'S A TUCK DRIVER IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ROAD AND YOU HIT
THE BRAKES, WHOA, THAT WAS
CLOSE.
>> Jesse: MAYBE THE PRODUCT HE
WAS SELLING JUST WASN'T THAT
GREAT.
>> HERE'S A TREAT.
THIS HERE IS A TREAT.
>> THAT'S A LITTLE SKIMPY IN THE
FRONT.
>> YOU JUST PUT IT IN THE
CORNER.
>> HAVEN'T YOU GOT A BIG TREE?
>> Jesse: FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS, THIS IS WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN DOING,
TRYING TO SELL US PHONEY
PRODUCTS THAT NOBODY WANTS.
THEY PUSHED CRT IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND PARENTS SAID, YEAH, NOT
HAPPENING.
THEY WANTED US TO DRIVE ELECTRIC
AND AMERICANS SAID THANKS, BUT
WE'LL PASS.
THEY EVEN TRIED TO SELL US ON
THE IDEA THAT WEARING A MASK
WILL SAVE YOUR LIFE.
BUT, YOU SEE, THIS WAS JUST THE
BEGINNING.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THEY CAN'T
CONVINCE US, SO NOW THEY'RE JUST
GOING TO TRY TO CONTROL US, AND
IT'S HAPPENING IN EVERY ASPECT
OF OUR LIVES.
LISTEN TO THIS.
DOCTORS IN CALIFORNIA CAN'T EVEN
GIVE OUT MEDICAL ADVICE WITHOUT
GOVERNMENT APPROVAL.
A NEW STATE LAW MAKES IT ILLEGAL
FOR A PHYSICIAN TO GIVE THEIR
INDEPENDENT OPINION ABOUT COVID
TO THEIR OWN PATIENTS.
IF THAT OPINION IS CONTRADICTED
BY CONTEMPORARY SCIENTIFIC
CONSENSUS.
AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WELL, IT'S PRETTY VAGUE BUT THE
STATE'S MEDICAL BOARD WILL
DECIDE WHAT THE SCIENTIFIC
CONSENSUS IS.
WHO'S ON THE MEDICAL BOARD?
HALF THE MEMBERS AREN'T EVEN
FENCE
PHYSICIANS.
THEY'RE MOSTLY LEFTISTS
APPOINTED BY GAVIN NEWSOME.
IT DOESN'T MATTER SCIENTIFIC
CONSENSUS HAS BEEN DANGEROUSLY
WRONG IN THE FIELD OF MEDICINE
FOR CENTURIES.
DEMOCRAT POLITICAL APPOINT TEASE
WHO HAVE NEVER GONE TO MEDICAL
SCHOOL WILL BE ABLE TO COME
BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR DOCTOR.
LIBERALS ARE ALWAYS TALKING
ABOUT MY BODY MY CHOICE, ABOUT
YOU NOW THERE'S GOING TO BE A
COMMISSION TELLING THEM THEY
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE?
AND IF YOU THINK THIS IS GOING
TO STOP WITH COVID, YOU'RE
WRONG.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF THIS
MEDICAL COMMISSION STARTED
OVERRULING DOCTORS ON A VARIETY
OF ISSUES.
CALIFORNIA BASICALLY JUST MADE
IT ILLEGAL TO GET A SECOND
OPINION.
AND THAT'S THE STRATEGY.
YOU DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR DOCTOR
ANYMORE.
YOU HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
GOVERNMENT.
THIS DIVIDE AND CONCUR STRATEGY
HAS BEEN PLAYING OUT FOR YEARS
LOOK AT THE BATTLE OVER RACE.
THE LEFT WANTS US TO BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE AND EVERYTHING IS
RACIST.
THEY WANT BLACKS TO HATE WHITES.
THEY WANT WHITES TO FEEL GUILTY
AND THEY WANT EVERYBODY TO BE
ANGRY.
BUT YOU SEE THE RACE RAGE IS
MANUFACTURED.
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA WANT US
TO THINK IS REAL BUT IN REALITY
ISN'T A PROBLEM.
THEY WANT TO MAKE THIS A PROBLEM
SO THEY CAN SOLVE IT.
AND IF YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
DEMOCRAT SOLUTIONS, YOU KNOW
THEY ONLY MAKE PROBLEMS WORSE.
TAMPA BAY BUCCANEERS HEAD COACH
TODD  BOWLS PERFECTLY.
HE'S ONE OF THE BLACK HEAD
COACHES IN THE NFL AND THE MEDIA
ASKED HIM ABOUT HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH ONE OF THE OTHER BLACK
COACHES, MIKE TOMLIN.
WHICH IS A WEIRD QUESTION TO ASK
ANYBODY.
>> YOU AND MIKE TOMLIN ARE TWO
OF THE BLACK HEAD COACHES IN THE
LEAGUE.
WHAT IS YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
HIM.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S A BIG
DEAL.
HE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO A
GOOD JOB AND HOPEFULLY HE DOES
IT.
WE COACH BALL WE DON'T LOOK AT
COLORS.
>> YOU UNDERSTAND REPRESENTATION
MATTERS WHEN ASPIRING COACHES OR
EVEN FOOTBALL PLAYERS, YOU KNOW,
THEY SEE SOMEONE THAT LOOKS LIKE
THEM AND GREW UP LIKE THEM.
THEY HAVE TO MEAN SOMETHING.
>> WHEN YOU SAY LOOKS LIKE YOU
GUYS AND LOOK LIKE THEM AND GREW
UP LIKE THEM MEANS WE'RE ODD
BALLS TO BEGIN WITH.
AND I THINK AS SOON AS YOU GUYS
STOP MAKING A BIG DEAL ABOUT IT
EVERYBODY ELSE WILL AS WELL.
>> Jesse: HEAR THAT YOU GUYS
MAKING A BIG DEAL ABOUT IT?
THE MEDIA.
DID YOU HEAR THE QUESTION SHE
ASKED HIM?
YOU ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
REPRESENTATION MATTERS TO YOU,
RIGHT?
LIKE SHE'S TELL THIS SUCCESSFUL
NFL HEAD COACH THAT HE NEEDS TO
SEE COLOR.
YOU'RE BLACK, YOU MUST THINK
LIKE THE LIBERALS DO.
HE SAYS NO, I'M JUST TRYING TO
WIN FOOTBALL GAMES AND I'M NO
DIFFERENT THAN WHITE COACHES.
WE ALL GREW UP IN AMERICA AND
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO WIN GAMES.
WHY ARE YOU TRYING TO MAKE US
SOUND SO DIFFERENT?
SPORTS IS ONE OF THE PLACES
WHERE RACE MATTERS THE LEAST,
IT'S ALL ABOUT WHAT YOU DO ON
THE FIELD.
AGAIN, THIS IS ALL ABOUT
CONTROL.
IF THE LEFT REMOVES MERIT FROM
THE EQUATION THEN EVERYTHING
BECOMES A POLITICALLY CORRECT
HUMAN RESOURCE EXERCISE, AN
EXERCISE THEY CAN DOMINATE
THROUGH ANGER, THROUGH GUILT,
FEAR BY MAKING THE RACES FEEL
SEPARATE AND UNEQUAL.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY,
NOTHING IS SCARIER THAN WHAT'S
UNFOLDING IN THE SCHOOLS.
THEY WANT TO SEPARATE KIDS FROM
THEIR PARENTS.
AND THEY'RE DOING THAT THROUGH
INDOCTRINATION STARTING AS YOUNG
AS SIX.
JUST THIS WEEK A CRAZY DEMOCRAT
IN VIRGINIA SAID SHE WANTS TO
CHARGE PARENTS WITH CHILD ABUSE
IF THEY DON'T AFFIRM THEIR KIDS'
GENDER IDENTITY.
SO BASICALLY IF NINE YEAR OLD
JACK GOES THROUGH A PHASE AND
TELLS HIS TEACHER, MS. DUGAN,
I'M A GIRL AND MRS. DUGAN SAYS
YOU CAN BE WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
BE JACK.
IF YOU WANT TO BE A GIRL, THAT'S
FINE.
AND JACK GOES HOME AND TELLS HIS
PARENTS SAYS MOMMY DADDY I'M A
GIRL NOW.
MRS. DUGAN SAID I CAN BE A GIRL
IF I WANT TO AND I WANT TO BE
JILL.
JILL'S MY NAME NOW.
AND THEN THE PARENT CALLS MS.
DUGAN AND SAYS WHAT THE HECK IS
GOING ON?
DID YOU SAY MY SON JACK IS NOW
JILL.
NOW MS. DUGAN CAN COME BACK AND
SAY, YOU'RE NO. AFFIRMING YOUR
OWN CHILD'S GENDER IDENTITY.
JACK IS JILL AND I'M CALLING
911.
COULD YOU IMAGINE POLICE SHOWING
UP TO THE PARENTS' HOUSE AND
PUTTING THEM IN HANDCUFFS FOR
CHILD ABUSE FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS?
WELL, ELIZABETH GUZMAN WANTS
THAT.
SHE'S A MEMBER OF THE VIRGINIA
HOUSE OF DELEGATES AND SHE'S
DRAFTING A BILL TO BE VOTED ON
NEXT SESSION TO MAKE IT A CRIME
IF PARENTS DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE
WHEN THEIR SON ORB DAUGHTER
CHANGES THEIR GENDER.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN SCHOOLS IS
THAT TEACHERS ARE ENCOURAGING
BOYS TO BECOME GIRLS AND GIRLS
TO BECOME BOYS AND TEACHERS ARE
CALLING YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER BY
A DIFFERENT PRONOUN AND HIDING
IT FROM THE PARENTS.
GOVERNOR GLENN YOUNGKIN IS
FIGHTING AGAINST THIS KIND OF
STUFF IN VIRGINIA.
HE INTRODUCED NEW SCHOOL
GUIDELINES THAT PREVENTS
TEACHERS FROM KEEPING THIS
INFORMATION FROM PARENTS.
BUT GUZMAN DIDN'T LIKE THAT AND
HER RESPONSE WAS TO SILENCE
PARENTS.
WHY?
BECAUSE SHE WANTS LGBTQ KIDS TO
KNOW THAT THEY'RE LOVED.
NOW, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU,
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE LOVE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE THESE TEACHERS
SHOULD MIND THEIR OWN BUSINESS.
HERE'S A FATHER OF TWO GIRLS WHO
TRAVELS COUNTRY TO PROTECT THE
SO-CALLED LOVE AND HE RAISES
THIS POINT.
>> OUR KIDS ARE BEING LED TO
BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE BORN WRONG,
BEING TAUGHT THROUGH SCHOOLS
THEY'RE BORN IN THE WRONG
BODIES.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
CAN ANY OF YOU TELL ME?
I KNOW YOU CAN'T, BECAUSE I'VE
ASKED THIS QUESTION THOUSANDS OF
TIMES AND NO ONE CAN ANSWER IT.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING.
WHAT IT IS, IS AN ABUSIVE STATE.
IMAGINE TELLING A CHILD THAT
THEY'RE BORN IN THE WRONG BODY?
AND CALLING THAT LOVE AND
AFFIRMATION.
AND THEN TELLING THEM THAT THE
WAY TO FIND THEIR TRUE SELF IS
TO BLOCK PUBERTY, GOING ON THE
OTHER SEX'S HORMONES AND CUT OFF
THEIR BREASTS.
>> Jesse: HE'S RIGHT.
ARE THESE PEOPLE TEACHING KIDS
TO LOVE THEMSELVES OR ARE THEY
TEACHING THEM TO CHANGE
THEMSELVES?
PARENTS ACROSS THE NATION ARE
FED UP.
AND, NO, IT'S NOT JUST THE
CONSERVATIVE WHITE DADS WHO ARE
SPEAKING OUT EVEN THOUGH THAT'S
WHAT THE MEDIA WANTS YOU TO
THINK.
IT'S ALL PARENTS.
>> WHERE'S THE MATH?
WHERE'S THE READING?
WHERE IS THE HISTORY?
WHERE ARE THE STRONG VALUES?
>> WE WANT KIDS TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THESE BOOKS.
IT'S NICE AND SIMPLE.
>> VOTE THEM OUT!
VOTE THEM OUT!
>> Jesse: THAT WAS VIDEO FROM A
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING IN DEARBORN
MICHIGAN.
THESE PARENTS DON'T WANT THEIR
KIDS READING BOOKS ABOUT TRANS
SEXUAL ASSAULTS.
THIS IS A MUSLIM COMMUNITIES
THAT FEELS THE EXACT SAME WAY
ABOUT THIS STUFF THAN BLACK
WHITE AND HISPANIC COMMUNITIES
FEEL AND IT'S NOT JUST WHAT'S
BEING TAUGHT IN THE CLASSROOM
IT'S ALSO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE CLASSROOM AND MAYBE THOSE
TWO THINGS ARE CONNECTED.
A MOM IN CALIFORNIA WAS FORCED
TO CONFRONT HER DAUGHTER'S
SCHOOL BOARD AFTER SHE WAS
EXPOSED TO ANOTHER BOY BEING
INAPPROPRIATE DURING CLASS.
>> ON MAY 17TH MY SEVENTH GRADE
DAUGHTER ALONG WITH EVERY OTHER
CLASSMATE WATCHED A BOY IN HER
CLASS MASTURBATE.
I ONLY KNOW THIS BECAUSE MY
DAUGHTER TOLD ME IN THE CAR WHEN
I PICKED HER UP SAYING HER
FRIENDS SAYING THEY WERE
DISTURBED TRAUMATIZED AND
SCARED.
IT DOES NOT TAKE AN EXPERT TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENS TO A 13
YEAR OLD BOY WHEN HE'S STARING
AT 13 YEAR OLD GIRLS WEARING
UNDERWEAR TO SCHOOL AND BEING
EXPOSED TO CONCEPTS LIKE ORAL
AND ANAL SEX.
>> Jesse: PRETTY DISGUSTING.
HOW DID THE SUPERINTENDENT
HANDLE IT?
>> WHEN WE TALK ABOUT MAST BAKES
THAT COULD BE RUBBING OF THEIR
JEANS WITH THEIR HANDS OUTSIDE
THEIR PANTS.
DOESN'T NECESSARILY NEED TO BE
INSIDE.
AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN AN
ELEMENTARY AND MIDDLE SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL I WOULD SAY THAT AT
LEAST ONCE A YEAR THIS COMES UP
FOR BOTH MALES AND FEMALES
WITHIN A SCHOOL SETTING.
AND SO I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
IS ANYTHING OUTSIDE THE NORM
THAT WOULD TAKE PLACE.
>> Jesse: YOU HEAR THAT?
TOTALLY NORMAL FOR STUDENTS TO
MASTURBATE IN CLASS.
NO BIG DEAL.
IT'S ALSO TOTALLY NORMAL FOR A
BIOLOGICAL BOY TO SPIKE A
VOLLEYBALL INTO A GIRL'S FACE
DURING A HIGH SCHOOL GIRL'S
VOLLEYBALL GAME.
THIS GIRL REPORTEDLY SUFFERED
HEAD AND NECK INJURIES BECAUSE
THIS GUY JUMPED 10 FEET IN THE
AIR, ALL MUSCLE AND SPIKED THE
BALL 600 MILES AN HOUR INTO HER
HEAD:  THE GUY LOOKS LIKE HE
SHOULD BE ON THE U.S. MEN'S
OLYMPIC VOLLEYBALL TEAM BUT HE'S
SPIKING BALLS INTO YOUR POOR
LITTLE GIRL'S FACE.
WHAT DO THEY CALL THIS?
THEY CALL THAT INCLUSION.
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY CALLS
THAT INSANITY.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN BOYS
BECOME GIRLS AND THEY PLAY IN
GIRLS SPORTS.
LITTLE JACK BECOMES JILL GOES
OUT FOR YOUR DAUGHTER'S SOFTBALL
TEAM AND CRUSHES A LINE DRIVE
INTO HER SCHOOL.
IT'S HURTING KIDS MENTALLY
EMOTIONALLY ACADEMICALLY AND NOW
PHYSICALLY.
AND IF A PART SAYS ANYTHING
THEY'RE A BIGOT.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS ALLOWED THIS.
IN FACT THE GOVERNMENT IS
PUSHING THIS.
THE GOVERNME